toujours en direct du circuit des 24
heures du mans à mes côtés jacques
laffite qui dans moins de trois heures
maintenant qu'il autres à une ligier
maserati jacques on dit que le circuit
du mans pour un pilote c'est
inintéressant
oui ce n'est pas très intéressant qu'une
du pilotage ce que plus les pilotes
ressentent ici est toujours intéressant
de venir au mans pour se faire connaître
du grand public une construire est
énormément de monde mais tout de même il
y à la ligne droite des hunaudières qui
est fascinant trois fêtes pour un pilote
oui elle est fascinante pour une
certaine vitesse de pointe que les
voisins les voitures atteignent dans
cette ligne droite mais c'est pas
toujours très agréable non plus d'aller
très très vite en ligne droite c'est un
peu lassant
jacques gagné au mans pour un pilote
qu'est ce que cela signifie maintenant
une très grande victoire
je pense personnel et est un très grande
renommée mondiale je crois très
important mais n'est ce pas d'abord
l'intérêt du constructeur qui prime
si vide évidemment reçu énormément
l'intérêt du constructeur pour lequel on
conduit généralement et des gens qui
l'aident mais surtout une grande
victoire pour le pilote et toute une
équipe
vous appartenez à une écurie dirigée par
un constructeur très sympathique guy
ligier comment est-il dit ce matin et il
en ce lieu
mais je crois qu'il est assez anxieux
d'abord ce qu'il à la grande crainte de
ne pas pouvoir terminer ces 24 heures on
dirait des petites raisons techniques
indépendantes de son équipe
les je crois qu'on il a un très bon
moral quand même ce qu'il a prouvé que
ces voitures étaient pour le moment
jusqu'à maintenant les terminer toutes
les courses assez bien placé et le
moteur boîte de vitesses tu as l'air de
marcher de fonctionner normalement et je
crois qu'on va quand même arriver à
terminer pour une fois les 24 heures
un mot sur la sécurité jacques pensez
vous qu ici sur le circuit du mans où
les voitures vont très vite tout était
fait et été mise en oeuvre pour la
sécurité des pilotes
non je ne crois pas c'est il ya beaucoup
de choses à dire je peux pas te c'est
assez long à expliquer il ya aussi le
dépassement de certaines voitures de
certains pilotes qui sont un peu moins
expérimentés que d'autres et ça pose
quand même pas mal de problèmes mais je
crois que la principale des choses et
que tous les pilotes conduisant nom soit
très très prudent que ce soit les
pilotes de grosses voitures lot de
petites voitures c'est ce qu'a dit qu'il
faudrait que tout le monde comprenne
très bien merci jacques de toute façon
je crois que les deux cent cinquante
mille personnes qui vont ce matc d'après
midi autour du circuit du mans vous
suivront avec attention
à propos ce public qui est il